in Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey a
bloodthirsty poo hunts for his
unsuspecting victims here's a look at
the Beloved character now transformed
from a honey-loving bear into a walking
nightmare ever since the Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey trailer hit the internet
back in August it has become clear that
this is not your average poo flick very
Loosely adapted from the work of A.A
Milne and E8 Shepherd the film purports
to introduce Pooh is a bloodthirsty
beast hell-bent on eliminating All
Humans from his path as for piglets
while he doesn't get off too easy either
in this version of the story The
adorable pig is now a total psycho swine
who will further Pooh's murderous
Mission at all costs just like his
character Pooh himself has been
distorted beyond recognition grotesque
and barbaric he strikes the imposing
figure of a beast all while wielding a
terrifying plastic grin and while Pooh's
appearance makes sense in the context of
the film who is essentially a Mindless
animal Now clobbered by life's cruelties
his soulless face still sends chills
down any poofan's spine but the best
part is that the actor who plays him
looks completely innocent according to
blood and Honey's director Reese Frank
Waterfield the new poo is nothing like
the friendly bear that children have
loved since the early 20th century as he
explained to variety last year Pooh and
piglet were left alone Long Ago by
Christopher Robin in the world of this
film who piglet
we were friends for many years and
they're out there he told variety
they've essentially become feral they're
like a vicious bear and pig who want to
go around and try and find prey
naturally a formidable looking actor
would have to take on such a terrifying
role but Craig David Doucet is by all
accounts an average guy he's still an
up-and-coming actor so he hasn't done
many interviews yet but he's perfectly
Charming in those that have made the
round so far on top of that he's already
set to appear in another horror film so
Blood and Honey fans can expect to see
more of him in the future before now
Craig David dauset's only acting credit
was for the horror flick the area 51
incident which was also directed by
break Waterfield but after Blood and
Honey douse it will appear in yet
another horror film the house the
zombies built not much is known about
the film yet but douse it is currently
credited as Roger the zombie Easter
Bunny which could signal another
childhood destroying role as a
bull-upped fantasy figure but perhaps
most auspicious for future fans of Blood
and Honey is the news at Frank
Waterfield plans to make more childhood
ruining cinematic adaptations of beloved
fantasy figures as he told The Hollywood
Reporter he's already cooked up a story
involving an evil Peter Pan and
overweight Tinkerbell who was recovering
from drug addiction and Peter Pan's
Neverland nightmare additionally Frank
Waterfield plans to make Bambi the
Reckoning which will tell the classic
story of a rabid baby deer who seeks
violent Revenge upon the humans who
sought to destroy his life of course
since thousand and Frank Waterfield have
collaborated twice now attracts that
they might continue their working
relationship on Frank waterfield's
Future 4 outings after all douse it
looks appropriately horrifying in his
low budget poo get up so it's not hard
to imagine him filling in the shoes of a
larger than life faked Bambi or of a
lumbering deadly Peter Pan for that
matter now we can only hope that Blood
and Honey drums up enough hype to fund
better costumes for those hypothetical
horror flicks of the future
foreign